bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france revenons pour commencer sur
l'enjeu de ce scrutin c'est le troisième
depuis 2018 et le dernier comme le
prévoyait l'accord de nouméa de 98
l'enjeu c'est l'accession de la nouvelle
calédonie à la pleine souveraineté est
ce qu'aujourd'hui c'est une possibilité
qui vous semblent pouvoir devenir
réalité
eh bien oui c'est justement pourquoi il
ya une consultation
les deux options peuvent l'emporter et
en plus comme vous l'avez souligné c'est
le troisième et dernier référendum qui
est prévu par l'accord de nouméa qui a
été signé par le fmi kayes et les non
indépendantistes ainsi que l'état donc
les scores des deux premiers étaient
assez serré donc l'enjeu du troisième
est bien réelle soit pour l'indépendance
pleine et entière soit pour le maintien
dans la république française le fln
caisse demande que le scrutin soit
reporté après la présidentielle est ce
qu'il ya consensus sur ce point auprès
de l'ensemble des courants
indépendantiste
bien le fait décoller c'est le principal
courant indépendantiste
il est celui qui fait l'opinion
indépendantiste donc pas reprend à
l'intérieur du fn grèce il n'y avait pas
d'accord
certains voulaient plutôt en 2021
d'autres en 2022 puis les opinions
changent et bien la réunion de paris un
parti du fn et ks
discuter avec l'état et les unions
d'indépendantistes au mois de mai puis
un compromis a été trouvé pour le 12
décembre suite ce parti l'union
calédonienne a réussi à rallier les deux
autres partis indépendantistes du fn
calais c'est le fait grèce avait accepté
la date du 12 décembre alors que lille
aurait souhaité plus tôt or 2022 film
donc là est intervenue
l'épidémie à partir du 6 septembre
et depuis plusieurs semaines des
dirigeants indépendantistes des partis
indépendantistes du fln as dit ce qu' il
faut reporter le référendum
naturellement leurs vis-à-vis non
indépendantiste souhaite le maintien et
le bureau politique du fn qu'elle est là
réaffirmer solennellement
qu'il souhaite le report des raisons
d'équité les cinq ans a reçu avant-hier
un soutien à l'onu qui ait le soutien
des pays mélanésiens de la région qui
ont une organisation et le représentant
de la papouasie nouvelle guinée à l'onu
est intervenue pour demander à la france
d'envisager le rebond
si la situation épidémique et continue à
être aussi mauvaise et au delà de ces
considérations sanitaires que met en
avant le fln caisse le fln caisse par
adresse qu'il ya aussi un jeu politique
quel est l'état des forces politiques
aujourd'hui dans l'archipel
allez on va dire qu'il ya un jeu
politique de jute de chaque côté parce
que le gouvernement monsieur le corps nu
et même le premier ministre on dit que
ils se donnaient quinze jours trois
semaines pour dire si le référendum
était maintenu donc c'est ensemble ce
hiatus qui permet aux forces politiques
calédoniennes chacun pour son option en
somme de demander le maintien ou de le
repousser donc il ya une part de jeu
politique mais il ya aussi une part de
2 contexte général bon il ya l'épidémie
avec la maladie la mort lé l'angoissent
dans la population c'est vrai il ya du
point de vue de l'état le fait qu'une
décision a été trouvée l'état soit là la
maintenir puisqu'une décision a été
trouvé il ya aussi un contexte politique
assez délicat et un peu inédit puisque
par exemple l'une des provinces de la
nouvelle-calédonie province des îles
loyauté qui est indépendantiste il ya
une majorité de ces élus ont écrit une
lettre pour refuser d'appliquer la
politique sanitaire du gouvernement
calédonien et du congrès de la nouvelle
calédonie à tel point que le président
de
l'autre province indépendantiste
monsieur erding qui a dirigeant
historique du mouvement indépendantiste
à lui mettre le holà et faire une
déclaration solennelle
soutenant la politique sanitaire du
gouvernement
calédonien donc il y à une ambiance
politique
qui est
très particulière et qu'on peut estimer
dans un contexte de campagne électorale
alors justement d'un beau et très
rapidement si vous le voulez bien est-ce
que reporter le scrutin après la
présidentielle est ce que ça pourrait
changer la donne politique
pas vraiment non ce nom va pas pas
vraiment
pas de raison objective que ça change la
donne politique
non je ne crois pas je pense que alors
évidemment ça regarderai
ensemble échéance soit l'indépendance
soit d'une discussion d'un autre statut
si la réponse est non ça c'est vrai mais
la phrase référendaire a commencé en
2018 et son terme c'est 2022
théoriquement théoriquement donc un
report de six à huit mois ne changerait
pas la donne politique
alors elle aggraverait encore un peu
plus la situation économique dans le
sens où la confiance c'est quelque chose
d'important pour les investisseurs
économie mais les voilà merci beaucoup
pour votre éclairage il se met à
khartoum que richie kurtovitch excusez
moi je rappelle que vous êtes historien
spécialiste heure où la nouvelle
calédonie